some directors love to throw all kinds
of extra treats
into their movies for eagle-eyed fans
many of these are discovered in the days
and weeks after the movie's release
but others can go unnoticed for much
longer here are some extremely
well-hidden easter eggs that you might
have missed
the films of pixar animation boasts a
universe of easter eggs unto itself
the pizza planet truck from the first
pixar film toy story
traditionally makes a subtle appearance
in every movie from the studio
the code a113 is another classic
reference that continues to appear
throughout pixar films
it's a nod to a classroom number at cal
arts where many of the studio's
animators went to school
however some of the other easter eggs
are a bit harder to spot
recognize or even fully understand for
example
buried deep inside of toy story 4
there's a reference to the 2020 pixar
film onward
but it's a bit of a journey to discover
it we're going on a quest
the strange thing is that onward was
released nearly a year after toy story 4
hit theaters in june 2019.
it's an extremely tough easter egg to
notice but in the film
woody buzz lightyear and the whole gang
end up at a fair
later in a mid-credit scene there's a
wide shot of the fairgrounds and it
includes a bouncy castle with an
illustration of pegasus the mythical
wing creature
it's the exact same image as the one
painted on the side of the van used by
the two adventurous elf brothers in
onward
of course there's no way viewers could
have made this connection until a year
after toy story
4 was released bizarre supernatural
phenomena are
given in marvel films but the 2016 entry
doctor strange fully embraces the
weirdness
benedict cumberbatch stars as the title
character an extremely successful
surgeon
who stumbles into a world of magic
sorcery and sentient caves
in this mind-bending film there's
another dimension lurking past the
mundane reality of everyday life
also the climax of the movie involves a
vicious time loop
this is time endless
looped time both of those themes are
also explored in the classic
1993 comedy groundhog day in which bill
murray plays a narcissistic weatherman
caught in a punishing loop where
february 2nd repeats
over and over until he becomes a better
person
do you ever have deja vu mrs lancaster i
don't think so but i could check with
the kitchen
a fundamental philosophy isn't the only
thing linking the otherwise unrelated
films
there's an easter egg in doctor strange
that references groundhog day
on february 2nd 2018 the actual
groundhog day
twitter user tim d lydon noted that the
car accident that sets doctor strange on
his new adventure
occurs on february 2nd when we pause the
movie the date is visible on the
character's watch
doctor strange's director scott
derrickson weighed in on the easter egg
congratulating the viewer on the
discovery he tweeted i've waited two
years for somebody to notice this before
the marvel cinematic universe made
superhero movies the standard
director sam raimi wedded appetites for
comic book based films with his
spider-man trilogy in the 2000s
the first installment 2002 spider-man
tells the origin story of how nerdy teen
photographer peter parker
is having a hard time fitting in at
school everything changes on a field
trip when he's bitten by a radioactive
spider
he quickly develops superhuman abilities
and learns the tough way that with great
power comes great responsibility
by 2007 spider-man 3 peter's struggling
with his dual identity
and the pressures of being a superhero
on top of that
he has to deal with an alien symbiote
that has brought out his emo side
and completely altered any dance skills
that he might have previously possessed
but amongst all the action and angst
there's a tiny easter egg in the film
that goes all the way back to the
beginning of the trilogy
in a brief close-up of peter's right
hand there's a noticeable bump or scar
the telltale sign of a spider bite or in
this case
a radioactive spider bite although
considering how bad peter's hand looked
in the first film it's nothing he should
get too emotional about
it was the snap heard around the world
and arguably the most stunning
cliffhanger since luke skywalker found
out darth vader was his father at the
end of the empire strikes back
in avengers infinity war the
extraterrestrial villain thanos collects
all of the powerful infinity stones
from around the universe uses them to
kill or more precisely
wipe from existence half of all living
things
for a time that meant the heartbreaking
end for spider-man
dr strange black panther winter soldier
scarlet witch and most of the guardians
of the galaxy
among many others while the on-screen
deaths were shocking and tragic
few avengers fans thought all those
iconic heroes would stay dead for very
long
and indeed most of those deaths were
reversed in avengers end game
but marvel wasn't ready to show its
cards quite yet the rapid-fire marvel
studios logo that starts each mcu film
and which features the images of
numerous marvel characters
was altered for avengers end game all
the heroes who lost their lives to
thanos in infinity war were removed
it flew by on movie screens so quickly
that viewers didn't fully notice until
end game was released on home video
and super fans could examine every frame
whether they're films tv shows or video
games media aimed at kids have been used
as a launch pad for toys and
merchandising tie-ins for decades
and your friendly neighborhood
spider-man is no exception
in fact long before the mcu took over
theaters around the world
the wall crawler spawned all sorts of
non-comics products and some of them
were notoriously bad
case in point the spider-man popsicle
with gumball eyes
of course disappointment plus time often
equals nostalgia
when spider-man into the spider-verse
was released in 2019
it mined spidey memories of decades past
in all sorts of ways
some of these references were pretty
obvious while others were easy to miss
however one of these easter eggs is
almost impossible to catch because he
only shows up in a single frame
after peter parker's version of
spider-man lists some of his merchandise
he delivers a funny line about being a
so-so popsicle
then there's a quick shot of him getting
slammed by doc ock however there's one
frame in that segment where
thanks to doc ock's grip spidey's face
looks a lot like one of those
infamously misshapen treats check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about
easter eggs are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one